YOU ARE OUT.
DEFENDING AMERICA IS SUDDENLY A
FIRING OFFENSE ON THE LEFT.
MARK LEARNED THIS THE HARD WAY.
HE WASN'T SIMPLY A LOYAL
DEMOCRAT.
HE WAS THE HEAD OF
ALLEGHENY COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, ALSO A MILITARY VETERAN.
YOU THINK HE WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
STICK UP FOR AMERICA ONCE IN A
WHILE, BUT NO.
HE MADE THE MISTAKE OF WRITING
THIS IN A FACEBOOK POST.
"I STAND FOR THE FLY, I KNEEL AT
THE CROSS.
NOT SO LONG AGO MOST DEMOCRATS
WOULD HAVE NODDED IN AGREEMENT
AT THAT, TODAY IT'S HATE SPEECH
AND HE LOST HIS JOB.
TONIGHT THERE LOSS IS OUR GAIN
AND MARK JOINS US NOW.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON THE
SHOW.
DID I MISS STATE THAT?
DID YOU HAVE TO LEAVE YOUR JOB
RUNNING THE COUNTY'S
REPUBLICAN -- THROUGHOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE OF
THOSE WORDS ON FACEBOOK?
>> I WAS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE COUNTY PARTY AND, YES,
BASICALLY THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED BECAUSE OF THAT POST,
WHICH I REMIND YOU WAS OVER A
YEAR AGO THAT I POSTED THAT.
I WAS ASKED TO RESIGN, YES.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE A VETERAN
AND YOU SAY YOU STAND FOR OUT
THE FLAG AND YOU WERE DENOUNCED
AS A RACIST FOR THAT.
>> CORRECT.
THE PEOPLE WHO BROUGHT THIS TO
LIGHT TRIED TO TIE IT TO THE NFL
PLAYERS TAKING ANY.
>> Tucker: SO, LOOK, I'M
CONFUSED.
I MET A DEMOCRATIC VOTER, NEVER
HAVE BEEN, BUT I'VE BEEN HERE A
LONG TIME.
I'VE KNOWN A LOT OF DECENT
PATRIOTIC DEMOCRATS.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THAT LONG
AGO IT WOULD'VE BEEN WEIRD FOR
THE HEAD OF A PENNSYLVANIA
DEMOCRATIC COUNTY PARTY TO SAY I
STAND FOR THE FLAG AND KNEEL
BEFORE THE CROSS.
WOULD IT HAVE BEEN FIVE YEARS
AGO?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU EVEN LAST
YEAR WHEN THE PITTSBURGH
STEELERS DECIDED TO STAY IN THE
LOCKER ROOM INSTEAD OF COME UP
WITH THE NATIONAL ANTHEM, ONE
PLAYER, AN ARMY RANGER, CAME OUT
AND STOOD BY HIMSELF WITH HIS
HAND OVER HIS HEART AND HE WAS
NOT CONSIDERED A RACIST.
EVEN AS MUCH AS A YEAR AGO, IT
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN UNHEARD OF
TO HEAR A LEADER IN THE PARTY
DEFEND THE FLAG.
>> Tucker: YOU WHERE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PARTY.
YOU OBVIOUSLY KNOW A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS INTERCOUNTY.
WHAT HAS YOUR FORMER COWORKER
SAID TO YOU SINCE THIS HAPPENED?
>> I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ANY OF
THEM.
I UNDERSTAND THE PARTY LINE IS
THAT IT IS A PERSONAL MATTER,
AND I CAN RESPECT THAT.
HOWEVER, THOSE THAT ARE ELECTED
OFFICIALS OR PARTY MEMBERS WHO
ARE NOT TIED WITH MY DIRECT SORT
OF CHANGE OF COMMAND, IF YOU
WILL, I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM ANY
OF THEM.
>> Tucker: 'S THAT'S SHOCKING.
WHAT DOES THIS SAY TO YOU ABOUT
HOW THE PARTY HAS CHANGED?
>> WELL, IT MAKES ME WONDER IF
THERE IS ROOM FOR MODERATE
DEMOCRATS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY NOWADAYS.
THERE WERE SOME ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO SAID THAT THEY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY'VE KNOWN
ME AND I AM NOT A RACIST.
HOWEVER, IT WAS INSENSITIVE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, IF MY
PATRIOTISM AND STANDING UP FOR
FAMILY FRIENDS HAS BECOME
INSENSITIVE, THEN I THINK WE AS
DEMOCRATS NEED TO STOP AND
REEVALUATE EXACTLY WHAT WE STAND
FOR.
>> Tucker: IF STANDING UP FOR
THE FLAG IS CONSIDERED RACIST,
THEN WHAT HAPPENS TO THE COUNTRY
DO YOU THINK GOING FORWARD?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I'M A LITTLE WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO?
>> WELL, I WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO BRING THIS TO LIGHT
AND CONTINUE TO VOICE CONCERN
FOR THIS VERY ISSUE.
AND THEN IN THE SHORT TERM,
IRONICALLY, MY SON IS GOING IN
THE AIR FORCE IN 60 DAYS SO I'M
GOING TO SPEND SOME TIME WITH
HIM, AND THEN I WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT THIS BECAUSE AS LONG AS I
CAN AND CONTINUE TO CLEAR MY
NAME.
>> Tucker: GOD BLESS.
AND LET ME JUST SAY, AGAIN, I'M
NOT A SUPPORTER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BUT I HOPE YOU